Joe Biden still drawing controversy
about the way he touches people at a
recent event he put his hand on the host
and then he joked I have permission and
now give him a break people ok I'm sorry
that's that's Dana one of our cue card
people Dana you think people should give
Biden a break yeah absolutely I saw that
apology video he put out last week and I
thought he looked really sorry yeah see
you
you think Biden needs to apologize
apologize for what for being friendly
and supportive well okay
some people are saying it's a
generational issue yeah I mean he is an
elderly man showing affection the way he
was taught to behave so so you think
it's a problem specifically with older
men
well not all old men Conan you've always
been very respectful
you know I'm not that old of course
you're not
you look very done I'm sorry what's your
what's your card say it says you're
great anyway thank you but back to Biden
do you think kiss is gonna hurt his
chances of becoming president
it could times have changed America no
longer tolerate sin appropriate touching
from our leaders I'm curious what do you
think the solution is well if things are
going to improve these men might have to
give up something that they enjoy and in
the long run I think we need to
re-educate men about physical boundaries
we all
we also need to confront toxic
masculinity and encourage other men to
call out improper behavior wherever they
see it yeah so we could we could also
elect women huh I never thought of that
hey name two cards everybody
[Applause]